[Music]
and gel billionaire news submitted by
power to the people
billionaire Jeffrey Epstein as Isis I
don't know epsteen epsteen
I don't know I'm hearing both I've hear
ball I've heard book yeah okay so he was
denied bail after being jailed for a
pending trial on sex trafficking charges
was he a billionaire yeah he made money
so here's a lot of people don't really
know so he was just a math teacher so I
forgot but he was a teacher right and he
decided to start working in Wall Street
and then he was working in like finance
and all that stuff but there's a huge
mystery on where his money's coming from
they just know that he's rich yeah he
also donates a lot of money to different
foundations and stuff like that but then
no one really questioned his money
that's what the speculation I think that
he is a pimp for high-class billionaires
politicians like that yeah so he was
arrested on July 6th after landing in
New Jersey for and charged with sex
trafficking dozens of girls from
2000-2005
no no and this is it the first time yes
so back this is god what 2008 he had
there were similar allegations against
him but he was able to plead guilty to
just two state charges he spent 13
months in jail on work release so he was
able to basically go back and forth what
from prison to his job and he sexually
assaulted two minors his job is as a
billionaire bro it was like olotele then
oh yeah so he wasn't really in trouble
and it's only thirteen wait he has
sought to to winery so this is what
happened so so I think they caught him
with like 36 or whatever but two of the
charges actually stuck a bunch of the
girls were gonna pull out their
testimony at the last minute
intimidation and money [ __ ] right so a
lot of so the art well there's two
arguments for this one right so the team
back then who was working in Florida the
US Attorney's team there one of them his
name is Alex Acosta and he was just
labor secretary but he just resigned
from the Trump administration because
there's a lot of heat coming down about
him being lenient on Epstein during this
he was one of the members of the team it
was who was giving Epstein like a pass
but he argues well all these all this
testimony was about to not be backed up
by the girls we were we having witnesses
pull out so we weren't gonna be able to
get him for much at all so that's why we
did that a lot of people say that sounds
like a [ __ ] excuse he was the client
it could be you know right he had a lot
of powerful clients well it all started
when a 14 year old girl told her parents
that she's got she got sexually
assaulted by Epstein and then they went
and you know they decided to look into
this and then it surfaced another
sixteen-year-old girl talking about it
as minors so he would he would um he
would host parties and he would meet
like invite everybody and they would
have families over in all kinds of [ __ ]
and he would he would try to working on
him yep
basically yeah and then he would get
other girls to get other girls and and
then he started to bait the conspiracy
behind it is he would get these girls
and prostitute them as well oh because
one of the things that he got charged
for was intent to sex traffic yes and so
and and one of the places that he was
doing this at that he was trying to
groom these chicks at was mar-a-lago
which is in Florida which is trumps
hotel that hasn't been connected to any
kind of crime or anything that's just
what's that's just true so well he has a
private island and they're calling that
the obscene has a private island oh my
they were they were flying these girls
into the island and and that's well
that's where some of it would happen we
don't we don't know that all of it
happened in these different places
there's been no proceeding yet that it's
tablished is like a timeline or any of
that [ __ ] yeah we just know that from
2002 to 2005 is when he's being charged
because there are two um victims here
who say that Epstein did all this to
them and so wait so they were flying I
can't talk to the island and then the
billionaire's would come to what are the
[ __ ] they wanted yeah and then what
happens to people like the little girls
do they like send them back to their
home after or that's what happened in
this case is that these girls yeah and
with the for the parents so they just
like push money all kinds of different
things how much money would you take for
them to be like we're gonna take Isaac
never how much various notes you also
got to remember that they have a lot of
powerful people because all the clients
that they have are like presidents and
royalty and like so now let's talk about
the Trump connection right that now
there's a bill clinton connection here
to which is that he and he came out like
as soon as this happened he came out and
released a statement saying I did go on
trips with Jeffrey Epstein only a couple
times he said if he said three times but
there's actually been there's multiple
checking about that and he took
apparently many more flights than he
he's on the manifest many more flights
including flights to the island and this
was that this was already a conspiracy
before this surfaced but Bill Clinton
says well I went with Secret Service
agents who obviously would not would
witness me and be Jill but there are
times where he was on the manifest and
the Secret Service agents were not oh
but he has not been accused of any crime
at all the plane is owned by M State
it's his private plane [ __ ] that's
disgusting yeah at least in this case he
was accused of rape by quaniee to
Broderick that's also part of that's
also part of what people are calling
like a wool he there's a pattern here
maybe but the Trump was also accused of
rape but in in I think two years ago or
something like that but that case was
also investigated and people a lot of
the journalists who were looking into it
felt that the witness was not credible
there was that quote from Trump to that
he was like basically I'll sting this
dude it's like he likes
girls kind of like me no he says he
likes young he's like he's like really
like into girls but then he was at the
end he goes he likes him a little young
yeah yeah yeah but it was I mean it
definitely sounds creepy yeah it's weird
it's weird it doesn't mean anything
right none of that means anything like
Bill Clinton being there doesn't mean
anything necessarily we don't know for
sure but it's just weird
no one's connections are a lot of weird
coincidence good I mean jeez even had
one of the royal members of England I
think it was a prince or someone that
was riding in his planes I mean this guy
is rich and powerful so he's gonna have
photos with almost everyone and anyone
so we just don't know who's really
involved so a reporter for the Miami
Herald recently said that they feel like
a lot of very powerful people or
sweating right now
because he's behind Mars and now there's
been a major development that happened
okay
so there's been a major development in
the story last night apparently he was
found having tried to commit suicide oh
my and he was caught with marks around
his neck and he was in a found on the
ground of a cell and now some people are
saying well he's connected to powerful
people nobody didn't try to kill him
yeah so he wasn't out there maybe it was
a failed attempt who knows like it was
like maybe maybe there was a noise maybe
somebody came didn't so these whistle
years and out them like he wasn't saying
he was there he was there he was there
what a totally speculation conspiracy
nobody knows anything I'm just saying
that that some people happen to having a
more Dane I know they were saying the
Clintons were involved somehow wait wait
didn't like the way that he cooked I
just remember they were blaming it on
the Clinton good question have they ever
tried to like tie all the missing
children who never like came up to this
island like maybe they're there L sex
sleeps I'm sure whatever's going on
they're not telling us about it that's
for sure I don't know about that
they've never been police officers in
that Island maybe they're still
currently investigating so they're not
releasing an innocent to the public just
yet
that is so [ __ ] scary this reminds me
of a post I read from a from a girl that
was she basically said I was sex traffic
at a high-level politics thing and and
so the way that this this went this goes
down in the way he throws his parties
it sounds like him because she was like
yeah I was in Washington DC and I was
going to these parties and then I got
recruited and then they were like how
would you like to spend a weekend with
this guy and then they were very upfront
there was a madam there and all that and
she was like [ __ ] it it's worth just
trying and I'll get all this money and
she was just actually kind of down for
it never been a prostitute never been as
in the seedy world just a clean-cut girl
right and then she says when she went
out it was like a British politician or
something and then there there she was
it's like escorted in a room that was
like super backdoor II and then like a
Jenny looked like the rest of them was
like a mansion and then she basically
was in a room and a guy came in and they
did it and she said it was super fast
and weird and stale and then she just
went home and they paid her all this
money one of the victims says that she
signed an affidavit saying that she saw
Bill Clinton on the island yeah which is
I mean is it a surprise though like Bill
Clinton is a notorious womanizer doesn't
it make me blank but it but it but it
but it's not a surprise like I'm just
not like it's not mr. Rogers it's Bill
Clinton right not that this is okay I'm
like door I'd expect Bill Clinton at a
brothel yeah yeah no but with underage
girls that's like that is next-level
though yeah that gets pretty nuts
because it's not secretaries it's now
like hella illegal yeah and the plane
it's called the Lolita expresses what
Epstein called the plane which is
obviously about them can you be that's
like the [ __ ] rape Express Express
that's the one with a younger girl
getting with the older guy right yeah
yeah and flight plane flight manifests
also show that apparently years ago
Trump was on the plane but not
necessarily to the island just that he
had shared a plane with the plane with
Epstein at some point well Trump's claim
Hillary's thinking
it's just probably like dude [ __ ] stop
like stop being a [ __ ] disgusting us
pain well that was in the past but I
mean you think that was the only time
no not even thing about that in terms of
the marital so I just thinking like
you're ruining our name our legacy yeah
stop embarrassing
I haven't had sex in years they probably
never had sex they probably won't I know
it was [ __ ] the heat they got his
sperm and they just [ __ ] with the
turkey baster
this is how they have sex there's a
conspiracy that Chelsea Clinton is
Webster Hubble's kid
oh you see it was a Clint Clinton friend
Hillary Clinton's friend and he helped
them during this thing called whitewater
and there's a whole [ __ ] bunch of
[ __ ] about it that's that's conspiracy
[ __ ] but it's fun yeah damn this is
crazy dude I'd rather hear about the
black matter in the [ __ ] universe you
try to figure that [ __ ] out it's less
it's less dark yeah yeah dark matter
isn't as dark as the Clinton well as
this whole situation see how much money
you can have that you're like nothing in
the world faces me I need to [ __ ]
children so that I feel fulfilled I'm
just rich it's just like people in
powerful positions they tend to do [ __ ]
like this like what it's so widespread
that during the Super Bowl that is
considered the sex trafficking like apex
the zenith because they move all these
chicks into town and like all these rich
guys like suits and they a lot of the
portion of the prostitutes are obviously
talking victims yeah like when we were
staying in a hotel me Joe Casey Bart
doing a writer's retreat they had a
little card at the front desk during
this time it was just long and it was
about I was like hey if you were being
trafficked this is what you can do right
now to let us know
tell hotel staff this was like an El
Segundo like just [ __ ] la LAX yeah it
was because I think they were doing that
nationwide because there's been a
crackdown on this chemistry yeah pretty
crazy
one like our three young looking Asian
boys so don't like do you guys need
helping me meet you no no no we're like
nah